à côté des cérémonies officielles les
enfants des écoles ceux de washington
notamment associer leurs prières à celle
de toute la communauté
la difficulté pour les plus petits de
comprendre ou de saisir la portée d'un
tel drame qu'ils ressentent
instinctivement tout était fait
aujourd'hui pour les encadrer et leur
expliquer à washington etienne leenhardt
dans cette école comme dans toutes les
écoles d'amérique on s'est associés ce
matin au deuil que traverse le pays
ah oui
les parents ont été invités et toutes
les classes rassemblés depuis deux jours
les enseignants ont laissé leurs élèves
exprimé avec leurs mots leurs angoisses
et leurs questions
j'ai cru que les états unis allaient
parce que vraiment personnel allait
résister c'était la fin du monde
l effet j'aurais espéré que les
terroristes trouve une autre solution
est celle de tuer des gens ni personnel
notre président explique le directeur
nous demande d'être derrière lui et
d'observer un moment de silence dans
l'école on a aussi discuté de l'avenir
et l'on y prêche la tolérance
george bush devrait avoir un plan
trouver ceux qui ont fait ça et les
mettre en prison
le président ne devra pas se venger trop
vite parce que la haine est la cause de
tout ça mais c'est d'amour dont nous
avons besoin c'est que nous leur disons
c'est que lancer des missiles sur un
pays sûr un homme sur un gros nous
appellera sans doute à court terme mais
que cela ne résoudra aucune question sur
le long terme
leur chanter la paix ce matin sans
savoir ce que réserveront les semaines
et les mois à venir comme leurs grands
parents se souviennent de pearl harbor
et leurs parents de l'assassinât de john
kennedy
cette date du 11 septembre 2001 ils
vivront sans doute avec pour le restant
de leurs jours